foreign
[Music]
dear friends welcome to this video um
before i start i want to praise allah
the most merciful the most trust or
praises glory and gratitude
belong to him as you guys can see i've
got flowers here just to make this a
positive
video no one's getting attacked no
refutations nobody's speaking just on
hijabis calm down
chill out relax i'm a bit agitated
because i had to
look for a stand for the camera as you
can see on the screen i had to pick
a uh bloody cat food box to put my
camera on as you can see on the camera
anyways moving on swiftly so guys now as
you guys
have seen or heard uh that drake
had a concert you guys know who drake is
i don't need to go into him for uh
his biography he's uh this video was
sent to me here
of drake in a concert pointing out to a
sister
right now before i say this i've done my
research i've looked into it i went on
to the video where
the page where the video was i looked
into the sections the the comment
section
and i wanted to know if this was set to
a sister or not you know because we
don't know
some people were saying okay no you said
to a white girl that i had a scarf on
then again i'm just thinking okay that's
a white sister maybe a real sister with
hijab
i don't know um someone say no it's just
a girl who had the scarf on then i'm
thinking
you know who has a scarf on in a concert
especially if you're normal and it can't
happen it can't happen but then again i
was thinking to myself also
that what will catch drake's attention
most likely
is a person with a hijab you know um now
the reason why i'm saying that is
obviously
let me show you guys the video right
let's watch the video for ourselves
first and let's understand what has been
said there put it into context
then we can come with uh what i'm about
to say with the gentleman the scene
shall i so you guys can benefit let's go
straight to that
[Music]
okay so basically what he's saying is
he's pointing out and be like hey i see
you four girls there
you know with that something with that
scarf on
etc you need to take that scarf so to me
it seems
like drake what will catch his attention
is okay
like what will seem abnormal to him is
like why is somebody got a scarf on yeah
i don't know if he knows okay she's a
muslim or not to me it seems like that
besides the point
when i was going through the comment
section i actually saw sisters
in hijab actually saying that they were
there that day yeah
so that's the reason why i'm doing this
video right now
i don't want it to seem like i'm only
pointing at sisters yeah because i know
brothers
attended that concert i'm sure brothers
went to that concert as well yeah
now my the reason why i'm doing this
video is just to make
my dear brothers and sisters understand
the sin that was committed there is a
sin
if you are a hijab is a sin if you did
wear a hijab is a sin if you had a beard
it's a sin if you didn't have a beard
this is sin if you are a muslim and you
believe allah is messenger
and the last day the day of judgment you
being there is a
sin because you're in an environment
right the prophet muhammad peace be upon
him said the time will come with
some people in my ummah will make music
sil
alcohol and and zinna permissible
now that's quite profound right okay
because
the disaster that the recipe for
disaster
is clubs like for example certain
environments like that
music yeah music plays a massive effect
on your body rem believe me
i used to listen to music i didn't do
drugs or alcohol back in my
india but music was something that would
just it was like a drop
music alco
dinner right these are the elements for
disaster
going to such places my dear brothers
and sisters and this goes for both
brothers
and sisters sisters in hijab or sisters
not in hijab
brothers in beard or no beard like i
said before
going to such places my dear brothers
and sisters is that you're opening the
door for fitna
and this is really sad you know why
because sometimes we
don't take the precautions how allah's
messenger tells us to abstain from
certain sins
and when we go to these places and into
these environments
and listening to the voice of the
shaytan which is the music
what happens is that we open the doors
to fitna
and when fitna comes trials and
tribulations
we we we open the doors we don't guard
ourselves towards them
and then when we get in trouble when we
get into a haram relationship
when we are intoxicated and something
happens when um
some people dying in that state and etc
and these open to different
things as well right drugs etc and then
we go through these tests and then what
do we do
on top of that disobeying our mind is
messenger put that to a side
what do we do we have the guts to point
out allah and say
why am i going through this test why why
is this happening to me
why is that happening to me but then
again do we ever ask ourselves like
did we do anything like we sometimes we
point out god it's not those individuals
who say hey people
are starving all around the world you
know why is god not doing anything and
i'm like well hold on a second
when was the last time you gave in
charity mate oh i've never so you're
pointing at god
god has given us enough food on this
planet to feed three more
planets right this is scientifically
proven three more planets because we're
selfish we blame god
it's the same thing we should abstain
from these sins brothers and sisters and
you know what's so sad
that this happens not only with drake
you've got drake pointing out to her
sister and telling her
to take a hijab off take a scarf off
right
now it's so sad that we've got like you
need to understand
as muslims either we're giving them that
they're giving us our so the fact that
he's telling
this sister right to take her scarf off
this is that it's just saying look move
that off you know
and what can you say like what can you
say to him no i'm not it's like i'm
saying okay
why are you here like in a way like look
take it off it's about to get
whatever whatever whatever yeah so what
he's trying to say is that look take it
off you know
so you can see the environment sisters
were like these are the same people
the same individuals who look at a woman
nothing but a sexual object
you are nothing but a piece of sexual
object to satisfy a man
to satisfy a man these are the same guys
who go
walk around in and in their trunks
they're talking about this is my
bee yeah i'm not going to go to what i'm
talking about she's my
ho yeah she's this she's that and then
we've got
girls in the clubs muslim non-muslim
dancing to that
dancing to a man calling them a whole
excuse my language yeah
you're you're this your dad and we've
got like can you imagine can you imagine
you're in the club dancing somebody's
saying
oh you are a this
you that somebody just swearing at you
and you're just there yeah just dancing
do you know how crazy that sounds so
this is what we're trying to say
sisters that islam we believe the
backbone of this um is our sisters
yeah and the the society is trying to
corrupt you guys the most
because you guys are the backbone you
guys are going to be the ones who will
be
educating the following the youth the
the the the future the youth of the
future you guys are going to give birth
to these kids males and females yeah and
if our sisters are lost in such
places where like subhanallah i'm trying
to say
like they say you educate a man you've
educated one man
you educate a female you've educated a
society
females is females are really important
and every single one of you guys are
sisters and we care about you that's why
i'm doing this video
and there's a profound statement i can't
remember who it was from but he said
half of the population of this world is
woman and they give birth to the other
half
so i just want to tell you guys that
look look at the life of israel
look at all those uh female companions
the wives of the prophet look at their
lives how it was my brothers and sisters
you know and this course with prophets
as well you've got brothers there
going there and this is this one thing
that i hate this hypocrisy of
we always pick on sisters right
i'm addressing both yeah because drake
pointed out that i'm just trying to
address it through that yeah
however it's the same with the brothers
you guys are expecting here i want a
sister that's good blah blah and you're
at drake's concert you're drinking
alcohol you have
you give like you do you don't do
nothing you don't do nothing and you
want a
a righteous girl you know fix yourself
first
fix yourself first this is really
important
and what i'm trying to say by this is
that some people come and say hey if
you're wearing
if you're going to a concert take your
hijab off no two wrongs don't make a
right
just because you're going to concert
doesn't mean you take your job off or
somebody says hey shave your beard if
you're going to go and do such things
this is ignorance if any of you guys are
advising
anyone to do that you guys are you guys
are absolutely ignorant
and you guys just rush just young rush
individuals
two wrongs don't make it right now those
sisters or those
may be making that mistake but at least
they've got the hijab one yes they're in
the wrong place we understand that
but what we're trying to address with
this is sisters look we understand
hijabis
brothers and beards where the full etc
we don't expect perfection from you guys
well we know that you guys have
struggled i have struggles
i'm not perfect we all have struggles
however there's certain things my dear
brothers and sisters
is that when you're in a hijab or you
have a beer and you have a foe
there's certain things that you don't do
in public
private okay that's between you and the
lord but doing it in public
you need to understand that what you
have this beard of mine
even though how little it is or me
wearing a foe or having a smoke in my
hand it represents that i'm a muslim
so if i go in crowd and start costing
people like hey you idiot
hey you this you die people can be
looking like wow okay so this
so automatically they're looking at you
out apparently thinking
you're a muslim it's the same with the
sisters in hijab that's your uniform
so let's just understand sisters that
let's just try to abstain doing these
things
in public now you guys might come and
say okay it was is
okay she went to a concert yeah okay it
was a private
a private sin of hers yeah okay you can
say it even though i was in a
public arena but the fact that drake was
boom pointed it out
it blasted so what i'm trying to say is
we don't expect perfection from you but
at least
let's not let's try to abstain from
damaging the name of islam
in the best way possible inshallah let's
just try to abstain doing things in
public
at least and let's not forget that the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him told
us
of the better man who approached i'm
going to cut it really short yeah i'm
nearly done yet
pray you sallah five times a day given
zakat fast when
fast in ramadan go hajj if you have the
means to and testify that there's
nothing worthy of worship except allah
and the prophet muhammad peace be upon
him is his final messenger
because allah says in the quran if you
abstain from major sins we will wipe
away your mindless sins
right and don't forget that and don't
forget that
every time you do something bad a bad
deed replace it with something good
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
told us any good deed wipes away
the bad deed i have flowers here if i
water these flowers it's a form of good
deed
right so let's keep that in mind and
let's understand that brothers and
sisters
that the people of the book will never
be happy with you
until you leave your religion right
until you leave a religion they will
never be happy with you and the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him told us in
the narration
that the people of the book if they
enter the lizards hold you will follow
them
you will follow them step by step span
by spam until they enter the license
hold you will enter the listeners whole
as well
so brothers and sisters let's be proud
of our religion well like this religion
this religion is from allah and by this
book
the quran allah raises the muslims and
is by this book that allah disgraces the
muslims you know
but like i said before don't give up
inshallah
inshallah this has helped you guys um i
hope i haven't been judgmental it's just
my way of
advising my brothers and sisters if you
know anyone that went to that concert
please please please do share this video
with uh with them inshallah
and like i said before hope you guys
have benefited please please please i
beg of you guys
please share this with your friends if
there was individuals who attended
uh this concert please do share it with
them inshallah maybe they will benefit
uh anything good that i've said is from
um
tala anything bad that i have said it's
from the shaytan and myself
so may allah grab every single one of
you guys janna hope you have benefited
from this video assalamu alaikum
[Music]
no